I guess just to start off what was the
first pet you ever had I always wanted a
dog okay they let me have a bird how do
you teach it to fly over I didn't teach
it it just didn't yeah oh my god yeah
[Laughter]
she wasn't my first pet though my first
pet was a rabbit Dee Dee's house rabbit
so he used to like be in the house yeah
he had like a little thing in the house
but he would make me be like free in the
house yeah do you start with the rabbit
and then sort of graduate okay buying
two dragons and yeah yeah can you do
tricks with like a bird or with like
with a rabbit is it um
rabbits don't really I mean maybe I'm
speaking out time I can't remember
really with it's really young not as
easily as with dogs like they want to
please so much that they all just you
know what about you with your bird Henry
actually um there's actually videos but
every time play the guitar
uh-huh it's a musician we just come in
my shoulder
oh and then while I'm playing you just
you just stay there well I'm
that's so cute I know I would take that
all the time and then like dogs
um they I think they feel when when
you're when you're lonely um so I'd be
working on something and then and then
just come over and come on did you ever
get a dog Henry no so I was really happy
that I could be part of this film
because I'm in the movie I had a dog and
I could actually pretend you know
finally at least pretend that I had I
had a dog so you guys get to bond with
the dogs before shooting or anything
like that what is the process of like
having a dog met them I think I met them
the first day we were shooting or I met
me the first step or the lemmy's know
the Mali is the first day of shooting um
but we were allowed to like interact
with them which I yeah which was cool
one thing I was really hard was just
like like while we were acting
we like to pet the dogs because they're
just so adorable right so that was one
challenge of that movie is easier to
work with dogs or your co-stars ignoring
that Henry's here but everyone was great
everyone was great to open on this it
really it wasn't like they were no
different everyone says that and it's
what I really want there were no days
where I was didn't it wasn't excited to
come to set and like work with the
people and the dogs the were I think the
dogs really helped with that cuz some
days you know you wake up and you're
like oh I do not want to go to where
when you get there and it's like yeah
they really helped nice that calming
presents for everyone I think I mean you
play a musician in this movie and you
are a musician how did you did you
collaborate did you give her any tips so
she was used to just constantly okay the
sing now she's in the next trailer next
to me and then I was like I kept kind of
listening my anyone days when it I was
like gonna play that chord this way my
shoes she was amazing she pulled it huh
mm-hmm
picked off a guitar since but I yeah can
do some way that song it's really bad my
calluses are gone like yeah yeah perfect
thank you guys so much